[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka guten abend im
dritten anlauf endlich am ziel friedrich
merz wurde heute zum neuen cdu chef
gekürt
erwartungsgemäß aber dass er ein so
gutes ergebnis erzielen würde damit
hatte er wohl selbst nicht gerechnet für
ihn beginnt ein neuer lebensabschnitt
auf denen er lange gewartet und gehofft
hat für die union endet heute endgültig
die ära merkel und zwar radikaler als
dass manche in der partei für möglich
und für wünschenswert gehalten haben sie
selbst war denn auch in jeder hinsicht
abwesend auch der rede des neuen cdu
parteichefs vom parteitag berichtet
mattes
es ist der moment hinter den kulissen
915 jahr stimmen 95 prozent zustimmung
das treibt sogar friedrich merz das
wasser
im ganzen land sehen delegierte nicht
nur einen großen vertrauensvorschuss
sondern auch dass ihr neuer vorsitzender
der sonst immer so beherrscht scheint
gefühle zeigt
ich nehme das wahlergebnis an und ich
bin tief bewegt und beeindruckt von
diesem wahlergebnis ich glaube das war
jetzt für ihn nach diesen letzten bundes
parteitagen wo es nicht gereicht hat
nach dieser mitgliederbefragung jetzt
einfach ein tolles zeichen dass so viele
delegierte gesagt haben wir schließen
und jetzt dem votum der mitglieder basis
an die cdu mitglieder haben bei
friedrich merz führung und attacke
bestellt eine attacke die er gleich bei
bundeskanzler olaf scholz einlöst als er
den für seine ukraine politik kritisiert
sie waren bisher weder in washington
noch in moskau und die deutsche und die
internationale öffentlichkeit erfährt
noch nicht einmal ob sie denn wenigstens
mit dem amerikanischen präsidenten und
dem russischen präsidenten sprechen und
märz erfüllt gleich noch eine zweite
anforderung das zusammenführen der
partei der wirtschaftsliberale märz
versöhnt sich sogar mit dem sozial
fühlen
friedrich merz hat in seiner rede ja
ganz klar als einen wichtigen aspekt die
soziale marktwirtschaft herausgestellt
und das soziale um genau diese botschaft
war für uns wichtig im sozialflügel war
es wichtig gewesen das ist doch die
lehre aus den letzten drei jahren dort
wo die geschlossenheit so nicht da wo
die repräsentanz nicht vollständig war
hat sich das im wahlniederlagen auch
gezeichnet und auch das verhältnis zur
csu soll sich wieder zum besseren wenden
das hatten merz und söder sich unlängst
versprochen ein garant vor bayerischer
kulisse ein versprechen dass der
csu-chef heute wiederholt arbeiten es
tut uns leid
und es tut mir leid und es muss und wird
anders werden um anschließend noch
während der dankesworte des neuen
cdu-chefs sich per zeitungsinterview von
dessen ukraine positionen zu
distanzieren keine waffenlieferungen für
die ukraine keine schärferen sanktionen
gegen russland auch keine gegen nord
stream zwei sagt söder der faz und
klingt wie der bundeskanzler wir haben
darüber gesprochen
zustimmung klingt anders und auch das
druckmittel nord stream zwei will merz
nicht vom tisch nehmen ist ultima ratio
wenn russland jetzt wirklich zu einem
angriff zu einer kooperation der ukraine
übergeht die cdu hat sich heute neu
aufgestellt ihre neue schlagkraft wo sie
erst noch beweisen
friedrich merz hatte allerdings kürzlich
selbst davon abgeraten russland aus dem
internationalen zahlungssystem swift
auszuschließen in der spd wiederum gibt
es hochrangige politiker die
ausschließen dass die gaspipeline nord
stream zwei als drohmittel gegenüber
russland ins feld geführt wird in der
deutschen politik schließen also reihum
ziemlich viele ziemlich viel aus dabei
wirken nicht nur cdu/csu untereinander
uneinig auch die ampel regierung hat
keinen klaren kurs zumindest keinen den
sie kommuniziert und dann hat sich noch
der chef der deutschen marine einer der
höchsten deutschen militärs geäußert und
damit ziemlichen wirbel ausgelöst
kiew hat daraufhin heute die deutsche
botschafterin zum gespräch einbestellt
dominik löschmeister berichtet
aussagen die irritieren vom obersten
chef der deutschen marine vizeadmiral
bei achim schönbach am freitag äußerte
sich bei einem offiziellen besuch in
indien zum konflikt zwischen russland
und der ukraine
will russland wirklich einen winzigen
streifen ukrainischen bodens oder in
sein land integrieren nein das ist
unsinn
weiter sagte der marinechef die
halbinsel krim saerbeck sie werde nicht
zurückkommen zu putins motivation
erklärt er
was er wirklich will ist respekt respekt
auf augenhöhe und mein gott jemanden
respekt entgegenzubringen kostet fast
nichts also würde man nicht fragen es
ist leicht ihm den respekt zu geben den
erfordert und den er vermutlich auch
verdient
aussagen die für wirbel sorgen die
ukraine bestellt die deutsche botschaft
darin ein vor einer stunde erklärt der
marinechef ich habe soeben die frau
bundesministerin der verteidigung
gebeten mich von meinen aufgaben und
pflichten als inspekteur der marine mit
sofortiger wirkung zu entbinden
christine lambrecht hat das gesuch
angenommen
nicht nur in kiew auch in anderen
osteuropäischen ländern allen voran
polen und das baltikum wird sehr genau
registriert wie sich deutschland
gegenüber putin positioniert allerdings
ist die ukraine darin auch kein in sich
geeint island im ukrainischen
grenzgebiet zu russland ist der blick
ein anderer als dem westlich
orientierten kiew annafest war für uns
in dieser region unterwegs
mitten im nirgendwo ein checkpoint knapp
2000 kilometer landgrenze teilt sich die
ukraine mit russland alle abendliche
grenzpatrouille des ukrainischen
militärs entlang des neuen schutzwalls
der soll panzer und militärfahrzeuge
abhalten sollte russland tatsächlich den
1 wagen die jahreszeit wäre günstig der
boden gefroren hart wie asphalt der
perfekte untergrund für russische
kampfpanzer colon
natürlich wird das nicht den feind
stoppen aber es wird helfen ihn
zumindest eine zeitlang aufzuhalten
angst haben sie hier keine behaupten sie
so sei das nun mal im krieg stunden
zuvor in cee regina bruder eine
kleinstadt mit 7000 einwohnern keine 50
meter vom russischen grenzzaun auf
ukrainischer seite liegt die datscha von
michael und seiner frau ludmilla hier
begegnen sie der angst mit galgenhumor
wir werden hier zuschauen wie russen und
ukrainer sich beschießen aber wir werden
in der mitte stehen und nichts
abbekommen
es sei ein einfaches leben das sie
führen arbeit gäbe es schon lange keine
mehr und nun dieser verfahrene situation
ein erklärungsversuch ganz standesgemäß
mit selbst gebrannten wodka es ist nicht
die ukraine die krieg gegen die russin
führt sondern es sind die amerikaner die
krieg führen gegen russland für michael
hat die ukraine bilder etwas in der nato
verloren noch in europäischen allianzen
und er sieht auch die ukraine in der
verantwortung schließlich würden doch
auch die ihre waffen auf russland
richten kein wunder also dass putin
aufrüsten du kommst zu mir mit krieg was
soll ich tun ich werde mich verteidigen
das sollte man den amerikanern und den
europäern sehr deutlich machen
zurück am checkpoint anders als viele
anwohner auch das ukrainische militär
auf finanzierung und militärische
unterstützung aus europa und amerika
denn sie wissen nur mit hilfe des
westens können sie putin etwas entgegen
setzen sollte es tatsächlich zum angriff
kommen
die ukraine das verhältnis zwischen nato
und russland
lasst uns schon bewegte und gefährliche
zeiten in der weltpolitik und mit der
nato geht es jetzt auch an den
nachrichten erst nochmal weiterhin die
usa haben ein neues nato manöver im
mittelmeer angekündigt dass am montag
beginnen soll
die übung stehen nicht im zusammenhang
mit der ukraine krise erklärte das
us-verteidigungsministerium
das manöver sei seit zwei jahren geplant
ein breites spektrum an fähigkeiten
sollte dabei getestet werden
die zahl der korona neuinfektionen in
deutschland ist weiter gestiegen
das robert koch institut meldet 135 1461
neue fälle binnen 24 stunden 57
1439 mehr als vor einer woche
179 todesfälle kamen hinzu die
bundesweite sieben tage incident steigt
auf 700
72,7
vor den corona beratungen von bund und
ländern an diesem montag haben heute
bereits die gesundheitsminister über
eine reihe von maßnahmen gesprochen ein
punkt sind die pcr test hier soll es
angesichts begrenzter laborkapazitäten
eine vorrangregelung geben erhalten
bleiben sollten sie unbedingt für
personal in krankenhäusern arztpraxen
und pflegeeinrichtungen sowie
hochrisikopatienten und personen mit dem
risiko schwerer krankheitsverläufe
sachsen anhalts gesundheitsministerin
können benne nach der schaltkonferenz
bei der spd ist heute das präsidium zur
jahresauftaktklausur zusammen gekommen
dabei ging es um weichenstellungen für
wichtige projekte mit blick auf die
derzeit hohen energiepreise und mögliche
entlastungen für die verbraucher hier
ist es am rande der klausur aus der
parteispitze dass man mit schnellen und
gemeinsamen ergebnissen in der koalition
rechne
für eine nachhaltige agrar und
ernährungspolitik hat heute in berlin
das bündnis wir haben es satt
demonstriert und zog mit traktoren zum
landwirtschaftsministerium eine
forderung mehr tempo beim umbau der
land- und lebensmittelwirtschaft
damit auch kleinere höfe überleben
bundesagrarminister erste mir sagte er
könne die forderungen eigentlich alle
unterschreiben die umsetzung dieser aber
nicht einfach
die völklinger hütte stein gehauene
erinnerung an die blütezeit der
industrialisierung als im saarland und
im ruhrgebiet die hochöfen kochten und
die großen stahl barone sich ihre
denkmäler setzen
die hütte ist weltweit das einzige
vollständig erhaltene eisenwerk aus
dieser zeit
1994 wurde sie von der unesco zum
weltkulturerbe erklärt die völklinger
hütte zu besichtigen ist an sich schon
beeindruckend dazu gibt es aktuell aber
auch noch jetzt eine ausstellung die
gerade auch für junge besucher einen
zusätzlichen reiz bietet sie widmet sich
dem musikvideo als kunstform susanne
freitag hat sich das angesehen
beziehungsweise angehört
[Musik]
ahorn awana queen madonna britney spears
und posiert flimmern über
riesenleinwände zwischen riesen maschen
musikvideo eine eigene kunstform
all die themen der gegenwart ki
umweltzerstörung politische gewalt
genderfragen all das bildet sich in den
musikvideos ab und es ist eben nicht in
quälend langen statements dort gebracht
sondern wirklich kreativ auf höchstform
durch die bunte welt der leinwände
begleitet 1 media guide das gerät
erkennt was auf die ohren
man bewegt sich in richtung eines
musikvideos hat man das auf den ohren in
der hand und das ist schon enorm ich
finds der wahnsinn also es sind so viele
gute videos und sachen die man auch
nicht so auf dem schirm hatte das war
vor zwölf jahren ein hit im netz ein
stück weiter billig
unterschiedliche stile und epochen
das hier ist vom künstler joseph beuys
[Musik]
rapper genetik aus saarbrücken
produzierte sein video hier in der
völklinger hütte
diese verbindung dass wir hier einen ort
der einzigen schwerindustrie der
eisenindustrie sind und jetzt sozusagen
die besten und die neuesten erzeugen
dass der musikindustrie zeigen
im untergeschoss hatten chef und kurator
ralf beil ganz neue räume erschlossen
hier werden die krasseren videos gezeigt
sie sind optisch abgegrenzt
pink yuki das video hat der
südafrikanische fotograf roger wellen
mitproduziert es war ein experiment
2012 war youtube die hüften und im netz
musik hören auch ein ganz neues denken
dann ging das freaky video online und
hatte sofort eine million klicks
unfassbar ich konnte das gar nicht
viel platz viel musik ein appell an den
tanz reflex der besucher dass die
einfach anfangen unwillkürlich sich zu
bewegen hier wirklich auch zu tanzen das
ist gerade in diesen zeiten wo wir
leider gar keine tanzveranstaltung
machen können im moment wegen einer
verordnung ist was ganz wichtig ist
eine bewegte reise durch die welt der
videos augen auf ohren an
[Musik]
und jetzt die lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
57 9 13 46 49 superzahl 5 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 6
es gibt weiter eine unwetterwarnung des
deutschen wetterdienstes vor starkem
schneefall für regionen im süden bayerns
und die wetteraussichten für morgen im
südwesten zunehmend sonnig sonst meist
stark bewölkt und vom erzgebirge bis
nach ostbayern noch etwas regen in
höheren lagen etwas schnee höchstwerte 2
bis 8 grad die weiteren aussichten in
den nächsten tagen vor allem im westen
und süden häufiger sonne sonst oft
bewölkt oder trüb aber nur ganz
vereinzelt etwas regen wenig
temperaturänderungen
das war's im heute-journal gleich geht
es im aktuellen sportstudio weiter unter
nach und 0 25 gibt es die nächste heute
express wiedersehen wieder sinn
[Musik]